[Music]
let's go to ashley in omaha what's up
ashley
hi dr john how are you good how are you
good awesome what's up
so my question is i am on baby step two
i'm paying off debt all right so
let me pause right here for our
listeners who don't know what that is
she's following the ramsey solutions get
out of debt plan which is a seven step
the baby steps we call it um step one to
save up a thousand bucks in step two is
pay off all of your debts smallest to
largest except for
your mortgage and so you are in baby
step two are you grinding it
i'm grinding it um how much debt you got
except
i have about thirty thousand dollars in
debt what is it
in loan
student loans
right oh man all right so you're
grinding it
so i'm grinding it and i'm killing it
um
my question and my concern though is
that i'm starting to run into some
health issues physical mental health
and
uh i have like 150 pounds to lose in
addition to battling depression and
anxiety
so i'm wondering how exactly to set kind
of some healthy boundaries while taking
care of myself while paying off all this
debt hmm
how do we get from seven-year-old ashley
to here
you've got a lot going on in your heart
oh goodness yes i do it was it was hard
for you to say i've got 150 pounds to
lose and mental health challenges
that was hard to say out loud yeah that
was really a brave thing i could hear in
your voice
walk me from seven-year-old ashley
tilner
uh seven-year-old ashley
let's see
seven-year-old ashley was just a child
always kind of struggled with her weight
always being made fun of
i've struggled with my weight since i
was little but i guess the big like
weight challenges started when i was in
high school okay
when you get you get a childhood of
you're not beautiful and we're making
fun and i can't believe you're wearing
that and all the noises and mean awful
things that elementary middle school
kids say each other
and yeah not only that but i'm also on
the autism spectrum that kind of made
things a lot worse absolutely right so
then you've got
connection challenges connecting with
other people and that makes it even
worse good grief man you got a lot um do
you have a supportive network
are you
mom and dad still in the picture
mom and dad are very much still in the
picture
he said that though it's not
i very much still have a tumor
are
you are you glad they're in your life or
no
oh i'm i'm glad that they're in my life
um it's just kind of yeah that was a bad
question that was a bad i didn't ask
that question
um
if you sat down with him tonight and
said i'm going to embark on
four big things at once i'm going to
lose 150 pounds i'm going to pay off
everything i own
i am going to
ultimately land a new job
and i'm going to
take control of my mental health
would they say would they get tears in
their eyes and say
you will have two cheerleaders one
running ahead of you and one running
behind you and we've got your back on
this deal
oh absolutely they would
yeah okay so why are they making your
life hard right now
um well it's hard for me right now just
because i live with them but i've also
had to step up
as a role the caregiver for my mom oh
gosh you're also a caregiver for your
like
what does that mean
um so she
has some health issues right now too
where she can hardly walk and they're
looking at potential surgery in the
future so i've been having to kind of
take more care of her and do stuff
around the house for her and my dad
how old are you
i'm 30.
why has this become your job to be their
caretaker
i figure
i'm not married i don't have kids i
figure
that you know i'm their daughter and
they want what's best for me and i just
want to
take care of them and just
certain things that i've seen with my
experiences in my life i've come to that
decision that i'm okay with being their
caretaker
sounds to me like you're drowning
sounds to me like you're slowly
suffocating
i do feel like i'm selfish yeah
you may have convinced yourself or
forced yourself
um but as the great vendor coke says
your body's keeping the score
and there's something codependent
there's something
unhealthy about the relationship and
interaction here
and
wanting to take care of your mom is a
beautiful wonderful thing
but if you do it and you die in the
process you've not helped
yeah
it sounds like you've lived a life of
i'm trying to disappear
i'm going to hide in plain sight i'll
hide behind my weight i'll hide behind
my fill in the blank
and this is a way you can help even
though helping
is killing you what i'd love to see you
do i'd love love to see you look in the
mirror and say what do i actually want
out of this one crazy life
that's exactly how i feel
so can i ask you what do you want
like snap your fingers and you're down
150 pounds
and you owe nobody anything nothing
and you've got a new car that you paid
for with cash it's not new it's like a
2019 or whatever
what would you do
oh gosh what would i do
if i was deaf free and if i
can i challenge you real quick
sure sure
the way you just said all the things in
the world makes it sound like it's
cinderella
and it's not
this is just getting your life back
this isn't a fantasy it's not a myth
this is right in front of you
and you my sister ashley
are worth laughing and being loved and
feeling good when you wake up and your
knees not hurting and your neck not
hurting and every time you get that
email from
sally mae your heart drops again
when your boss treats you like crap and
you think i'm i'm worth more than you're
worth all of that and this is not a
pixar
movie this is your life
what would you do
what would you do
um
i don't know i mean
i've never really
thought that far out advanced
okay
i bet if you and i spent an hour or two
together
we could you could walk me back through
some things that you think are pretty
normal about how you grew up and how you
were treated
and that i would probably be looking at
you with my mouth wide open
you've seen and experienced a lot
haven't you
yes you have
and people have hurt you haven't they
so the
heart the hard path here is
saying this stuff happened
and yet i'm worth more
so
so much more
yeah
so here's how you prioritize your health
you look in the mirror today and you say
i'm worth feeling good
i'm worth my dad getting up and he can
help his wife
because he's a grown man
my mom has struggles and we can
negotiate i might be able to help but
i'm gonna make a plan to at least
consider moving out
i'm going to continue to pay off my
debts in the baby steps way the same way
i'm going to be about changing the way i
treat my body
because i'm worth being loved
and right now you hate yourself and you
treat your body in a similar way is that
fair
it's very sure okay no more today
i'm not going to let anybody hate ashley
because ashley's awesome
because you got a great great heart
and nobody's giving you any tools to
show the world how that thing works
okay
okay i think after 30 years i think it's
going to be very very difficult to
impossible to do this on your own you've
been in counseling you said
yes
has it been effective or no
i'm guessing not
not really and i'm trying to find
another counselor okay
so i'm gonna do a couple of things for
you today okay
today is just the start
today is when we turn the lights on okay
and your homework assignment is this i'm
gonna trade you a lot of cool stuff for
your homework assignment fair
your homework assignment is i'm gonna
write ashley a letter
and it's gonna have three parts to it
part number one
here's what happened
part number two
owning where we are right now
i owe 30 000 bucks in student loans
probably for a degree i'm not even using
i'm 30 and i live with my parents
um we didn't even talk about your
romantic situation or anything like that
i am dealing with a highly codependent
set of parents who are expecting this
and that and i've just talked to myself
into x y or z and my body's falling
apart on me and i and my mental health
is really struggling i'm isolated alone
then the third part of this letter is
going to be you saying here's what this
could look like
because if you don't have a place that
you're going you're not going to get
anywhere
if you don't have a picture of i want
you to dream
as clear as possible
the house will look like this the job
will look like this
the person i'm dating will look like
this the car will look like this my bank
account will look like this and i'm not
doing this in some like
manifest and that's nonsense i'm saying
you've got to have a picture that you
are going to walk towards
and you saying i've never even thought
about that
you're worth a beautiful picture and if
you will do that i want you to um write
this down and i want you to either mail
it to me or email it to me okay that's
your accountability cool
okay that sounds good for that i'm going
to do a couple of things i'm going to
give you a year subscription to ramsey
plus
okay
that comes with the
the
the ramsey solutions app that for
tracking every dollar app that tracks
all of your expenses it's everybody
around here uses it it's incredible it's
the best one on the market
um it also has all of the financial
piece videos that walks you through all
the baby steps if you actually want to
get out of debt
and it's got all kind of other stuff in
there tons of
encouraging things questions all that
kind of stuff you got to use it though
but i'm going to send it to you and give
you a year subscription okay and
i'm going to send you a copy of my new
book own your past change your future so
we're talking about you gotta own what
happened own reality and then make a
plan for what comes next and that book
will walk you step by step by step
through it okay the third thing i'm
gonna send you is my friend ken's book
paycheck to purpose
i want you to start dreaming about what
kind of work you can contribute to in
this world
and maybe it's taking care of your mom
but if it's taking care of your mom then
your dad's gonna pay you a salary
okay okay you're not gonna be a free
stay-at-home nurse for your family
okay cool
that sounds good and my hope the next
time i talk to you you are six inches
taller
not in reality but in the way you talk
to and look at and love ashley
will you say that out loud i'm worth
being loved
i am worth being loved and i can't wait
to call you back after i've done all
this and give you an update yes ashley
i love it